hey guys Ryan right here it's 5 o'clock
in the morning right now I cannot sleep
it's one of those things where I'm tired
but I can't sleep as I took a nap after
work and then I was like oh crap now I
can't go back to sleep and if I go to
sleep now I might oversleep it I might
miss work and right now really can't
afford to [ __ ] up on my job especially
since the person who snitched on me just
cut the axe that's why I'm awake and I
decided what better way to kill time
then watch some spider-man regular
because they can't stop releasing these
damn clips for some reason they have an
alternate final trailer just when you
think they have stopped with the
trailers they said why don't we put out
an alternate take on the final trailer
and there's an alternate TV spot number
two and something about a baby don't
really know that is I'm gonna check out
all three right now another spiders on
four yep
so yeah let's get this spider show on
the road oh here we go
first we're gonna start off with the
official extended TV spot number two oh
they just don't know when to stop but
I'm sure their trailer is gonna be
awesome
I once told you that secret's out cause
the truth does - yes it does Peter I
know us Corp is capable
they'll know find spider-man why I'm
dying
it's not that soon see really I wish I
was like the amazing spider-man
hey spider-man please haha
what should make spider-man bleed
look at the new Peter
whoa hey
every decision you make affects the
people in love know how he got her rid
of pg13 I think you spot gave me chills
man how does she die in this one because
I know she dies in the comics sorry for
anyone who did not know that but she
does get killed by the green guy look I
believe so does she die in the movie - I
don't know
that's what May 2nd is for is to find
out but you know what that wasn't enough
footage we need to watch more because I
just need to for myself for my own
well-being and I'm so happy they have an
alternate final trailer you might have
thought it was over with the trailers
but no you know what it is all about the
Spider Man a wet dick he'll never get
over that
nice lucky [ __ ] Peter Parker very
onboard it's been ten years what have
you been up to
Willy Wonka design
I want to be in so bad you under
surveillance
why is not questionable
what I thought it was
now Richard Parker I have discovered
what Oscorp was going to use my research
for the future we have plans for you
Peter Parker
we have about now we can change the
world
let's go gotta slide
shit's about to go down this is what
I'm the only one who can stop
I'm spider-man
I hope so whoa you get more gobby
talk about ruining a great fight the
amazing spider-man 2 oh my god oh I'm
doing with you for mr. Bator sorry I
love you don't hate me
whoa Eddie no he blasted away the rocket
that was cool well I'm a little
spider-man out I wish they didn't show
any of that fight with the Green Goblin
I wish they didn't ruin anything with
the Green Goblin actually I thought it
would have been cooler if you know they
teased Harry Osborn and then you know
Green Goblin makes us a prize like think
about the Dark Knight they didn't show
to face in the trailers they just showed
Harvey Dent and I wish they did the same
thing here it would have been much more
interesting I wouldn't get so worried
about too many villains the movie still
does look really good you know I've
heard some early reactions are a little
bit mixed on it but you know what [ __ ]
that [ __ ] have your own goddamn opinion
about the movie people have been telling
me about this trailer the CV and heavy
and baby and me don't know what the [ __ ]
this is but they've all been saying I
should check out this trailer and that
it's a good time so let's get our
spider-man thawne to an end I'm hoping
this is the last time I see a trailer
based off the spider-man 2 movie
it's pretty cool
oh how cute that is pretty adorable
they should be the movie school
what's this
oh it's a defense of water commercial it
not realized that that was pretty
[ __ ] cool I wish that could be
included in the movie somehow with its
really serious tone but throwing that
random absurd out of place comedy you
get one film that people would hate but
I get a kick out of
anyway dudes if you're new to the
channel subscribe because I watch a lot
of these this is what I do on my spare
time that watch trailers and of course
it's become that time of the video
shout out time heard my neighbor telling
me to keep it down earlier today that's
what I'm trying to keep my voice
reasonably temperature level temperature
room tone level don't I got temperature
from Edmund McKinley homeboy said he
wanted a shout out on the spot two clips
or whatever it is that we're watching so
shout out to you
Edmund I think I've ever worked for long
every time I hear the name Edmund peanut
boy peanut boy gave me one hell of a
compliment he said he got a YouTube
account just so he gets subscribed to
this channel so thanks peanut boy suck
on your peanuts any day little boy you
whoa that sentence came off really wrong
gargoyle senior did dibs on a shout-out
so just wanted to say what's up you know
I think a gargoyle senior I think of the
Ed Asner character in the show gargoyles
you guys remember show there's like a
grandpa character he has you know that
as Mary Tyler Moore Show the Lou Grant
show roots bunch of other [ __ ] he played
Santa Claus in the health movie that's
probably well you guys know him from